un discurso del presidente Manuel
enfocado en la nueva estrategia
diplomática y militar de Francia en el
continente africano es la antesala de su
gira por gabón Angola el Congo y
República democrática del Congo que
comenzará el miércoles sin embargo los
países del sagel no figuran en su agenda
pero el propósito del Eliseo es
contrarrestar la creciente influencia
rusa y china en los países africanos
francoparlantes amenaza materializada en
Mali país del sahel que prefirió a Moscú
y a la milicia paramilitar Wagner para
combatir a los grupos yihadistas
obligando el repliegue de las tropas
francesas y el fin de la operación
antiterrorista barcán
retiro que también se hizo efectivo con
el fin de la misión francesa en burkina
faso el descontento africano con Francia
no sólo es producto del pasado reciente
colonizador también nace el apoyo de
París a varios regímenes dictatoriales
alrededor del continente sin embargo
makon Busca presentarse como el
dirigente de una nueva generación que no
le África lo que debe hacer y ha
afirmado que los crímenes de la
colonización son indiscutibles como
gesto de arrepentimiento prometió
devolver 26 obras de arte robadas a
benim macón Quiere pasar la página de
Lake política poscolonial de París y
tender la mano a la juventud africana
durante su segundo mandato como
presidente de la quinta República su
apuesta es en un principio con los
francófonos de África que se estiman en
150 millones de personas en 32 países
prueba de ello son los 3000 soldados
desplegados en níger y Chad que pretende
aumentar a 5.500 y su intención de
rearticular el sistema militar francés
en los países del Golfo de Guinea
macón prevé realizar visitas al
continente por lo menos cada seis meses